big news of the day yesterday and
honestly historic news the death of
rush limbaugh so for those of you who
never listened to russia missed out
rush was the granddaddy not only of talk
radio but of all the alternative media
without rush limbaugh there is no
alternative media
you have to understand what rush was and
what he was not so
what he was not is what the media are
calling him today a bigot
a vicious terrible person saying the
world is better off
because he is dead this is stuff that
you are seeing in mainstream media
outlets
it's stuff that you're seeing certainly
on twitter which allowed rot in hell to
trend
when rush limbaugh died as well as rest
in piss
you can tell that the left really didn't
like this guy here's the thing the
reason they didn't like rush
is because they kept trying to cancel
him and they kept failing the reason
they didn't like rush is because
rush provided an alternative until there
was rush there was a media monopoly in
this country on the left
rush was the first point of push back to
that now there have been conservatives
who've been on mainstream television
before milton friedman's free to choose
aired on pbs
and william f buckley's firing line was
also on pbs but
that was basically conservatives
existing at the suffrance of liberal
liberal overlords in the media the
reality is that
at the very beginning there were just
three networks abc nbc cbs all of them
lean to the left
virtually every major newspaper in the
united states lean to the left
and when it came to radio radio was
basically a dead medium certainly the am
band was a dead medium
it was really hard to listen to the
quality was really staticky
it was a bad place for music right all
of the music had had
migrated over to fm so am radio was
basically dead
and the fairness doctrine ruled the
fairness doctrine was this
unconstitutional
i think doctrine that suggested that if
you had a broadcast license
you had to be fair in your presentation
of the issues which was a completely
subjective
interpretation because there was no way
that folks with broadcast licenses were
being fair in their presentation of the
issues they certainly were not providing
all sides
of any particular issue well in 1987 the
fcc under ronald reagan
got rid of the fairness doctrine and in
doing so they opened the path to am
radio because they allowed people with
broadcast licenses
to stop worrying about government
mastering them and start worrying about
what the market wanted to hear
in 1989 rush limbaugh launches the rush
limbaugh show
and it immediately becomes a sensation
and it becomes a sensation because
there's an entire side of the political
aisle that for decades has had no
daily outlet for the news remember
there's no major mainstream newspaper
that was right wing
there was no television state fox news
did not exist none of this
infrastructure existed and when it came
to daily news there was no internet
so that meant that all the news that you
ever got was daily news from the left
and even those shows that i mentioned
before a special like milton friedman
that happened once in a blue moon
and william f buckley that might happen
once a week but it certainly wasn't
every day it certainly wasn't the
commentary on the narrative as it was
being spun out by the left
in real time so rush comes along and
rush
is maybe the most talented person ever
to enter the radio medium i mean
probably without question he's the most
talented person
ever to enter the radio medium he
single-handedly makes the am
band a thing because suddenly here is a
person who is funny this is what drives
left
absolutely up a wall is the fact that
rush was a funny person right rush was
entertaining and rush saw himself as an
entertainer
he called himself a lovable little
fuzzball he talked about i was gonna
fight the left with one half of his
brain tied behind his back
talent's on loan from god and all this
is all tongue-in-cheek kind of stuff
and rush approached the issues with
humor and this made him
entertaining and subversive and the left
could not handle it and if you talk to
any conservative born after 1960
russia was a seminal figure in their
life people of my age range
we listen to rush because my dad was
listening to russia in the car
on the way to ucla when he was driving
me to ucla some days it would be rush
limbaugh on in the car and then when i
was driving myself in my 1986 honda
civic with no air conditioner
it was listening to rush on my way in
the car and rush was defiant
in his resistance of liberal narratives
russia was willing to say things
that were true but that might not please
the people on the left
and this gave a lot of people courage he
gave me courage when i was in class
it gave me weapons to argue my position
when i was at ucla
now left today will tell you that russia
is a polarizing figure super
oppositional super terrible
here's the reality the left had a
monopoly anybody who breaks a monopoly
is seen by the monopolist
as defiant and oppositional that's the
way this works
everybody on the right right now who
refuses to kowtow to the woke
authoritarian left line
is seen as oppositional and polarizing
and defiant it doesn't matter
that people like me do the sunday
special every week
and many weeks it is people on the left
that does not matter
none of that really makes a difference
the idea is that anybody who speaks up
against the left is the cause of the
polarization because the left should
have complete dominance
rush was the first person to deny this
russia was the first person to say
listen
i exist you exist i hear you and you
hear me
and we can communicate with each other
you the conservative living in the
middle of the country who's been
completely overlooked by the
establishment media
you have a voice and you have a place
you can go
to hear people who agree with you and
you have arguments that you can leverage
in support of your viewpoint this is why
the left was so frightened of rush
limbaugh because rush was entertaining
because rush did have a big crowd
it's why the left decided they were
going to go after him i think it is fair
to say
that if it were not for rush there would
not be this entire left-wing apparatus
designed at destroying people in
right-wing media because there wouldn't
be a right-wing media
fox news would not exist without rush
limbaugh rush limbaugh was the test case
he was the canary in the coal mine
for the suggestion that there was in
fact a massive market for conservative
content
in the united states because again the
methods of dissemination just didn't
exist
to that point so rush was a deeply
important figure in the history of
conservatism he also had a gift for
distilling down complex arguments to
something more simple
and william f buckley was famously
sesquipedalian right he would use words
that nobody knew
right he was extraordinarily literate
but this didn't exactly
make him always the best expositor of
conservative to the truck driver
to the guy who didn't go to college rush
was the guy who talked to everyone
russia never talked down to anyone and
listen i'm a huge buckley fan but there
is no question that
buckley's chief audience was college
graduates people who read national
review are not the same people who
listen to talk radio
rush was the person who brought
conservatism to the common man which is
why you saw in 1994
after newt gingrich became speaker of
the house rush was given an honorary
congressional seat by
members of the of the republican party
in congress
you know russia's willingness and
ability to explain conservative
viewpoints
made him unique in the space and also
made him the target of unique ire from
the left
very early on the left identified him as
a threat and then they dedicated nearly
everything in their arsenal to
destroying him
a lot of the same stuff that you see
today started with rush the attempts to
de-platform
the attempts to go after his advertisers
all that started with rush
the attempt to blame people on the right
for violence with which they had nothing
to do
that all started with rush i'm old
enough to remember when the left tried
to blame rush for the oklahoma city
bombing
so rush was just the first guy there and
not only the first guy there the most
talented guy there
and you can sense how important rush was
by the amount that the left hates him
despises
him i mean after after he died again
the reaction from the left which is
sometimes muted depending on who dies
was absolutely unbridled absolutely
unbridled
and to pretend by the way that this
exists equally on both sides of the
aisle is is very silly
when ruth bader ginsburg died there
weren't people on the right who were
talking about what a terrible evil
person she was in the world is better
off without her because
it wasn't true but with the left the
idea is that rush limbaugh was the font
head of all evil
especially because of course donald
trump had just been elected president of
the united states and he'd been
president of the united states and
russia been a big trump supporter
but for those of us who listened to rush
for 30 years long before trump
was ever even in the rearview mirror we
recognized that trust
we recognized that russia's legacy was
way more than that
it was giving people a voice it was
making people feel heard and more
importantly it was beginning a mass
movement in favor of conservatism that
actually had alternative outlets daily
wire
would not exist were not for rush
limbaugh this podcast would not exist
where not for rush limbaugh certainly
this radio show
would not exist or not for rush limbaugh
rush built this
right we're all sort of living in the
house that rush built rush limbaugh's
wife katherine
made an announcement on his show
wednesday morning
she said losing a loved one is terribly
difficult even more so when that loved
one is larger than life rush will
forever be the greatest
of all time and that of course is true
just speaking of his life rush limbaugh
got started as a morning talk show host
in 1983
at kansas city's kmbc he went to
california's kfbk in sacramento in 1986
and in 1988 he relocated to new york and
signed his syndication deal for the rush
limbaugh show
his daily show on new york's wabc aired
on 56 networks eventually grew
into the most listened to radio program
of all time it reached more than 600
stations
and an an estimated audience of some 27
million listeners according to emily's
an audio over at daily wire
in 1993 limbo was inducted as a member
of the national radio hall of fame
in many ways he shaped the modern
republican party he was an early
supporter of the tea parties in
20 in 2009 and then presidential
candidate donald trump
in 2016 of course limbaugh said several
years ago we stood for the concepts that
are in our declaration of independence
right to life liberty pursuit of
happiness we stood for that we're the
beacon for it to this day that is why
the oppressed of the world still seek to
come
to this country okay and you can
i mean the the the reaction on the right
is universal warning
the editorial board of the wall street
journal says a familiar voice in
american media and politics has gone
quiet rush limbaugh the most listened to
radio host in america for 30 years died
wednesday at age 70.
we recall how bracing the rush limbaugh
show was in its early days for decades
the airways
had been governed by the fairness
doctrine a federal regulation requiring
stations to balance quote unquote
controversial claims with contrasting
viewpoints
the rule gave incumbent candidates and
mainstream news outlets in near monopoly
on public discourse
reagan scrapped the fairness doctrine in
1987 by the 1992 presidential campaign
the radio star's first name was known
across the united states
he was invaluable to the conservative
movement of the 90s he would spend an
hour explaining supply-side tax policy
or making the case for your regulation
millions of americans had never heard a
coherent argument against the welfare
state or roe vs wade until they tuned in
to limbaugh's show
he played an enormous role in
popularizing conservative ideas and
policies
his critics called him a racist and
about everything else which was always
unfair his real offense was to gain
millions of weekly listeners by mocking
the left's pieties he dissected
environmental scare campaigns he
ridiculed the news media for finding
epidemics of homelessness only during
republican administrations
in 1994 bill clinton called the st louis
radio station from air force one to
complain about limbaugh's criticism not
for the last time blaming scrappy radio
hosts for his own political woes
in recent years with the rise of more
acerbic competitors and a general
souring of public discourse limbaugh
took on a more exasperated tone says the
wall street journal he also moved to the
trumpian rate on issues like trade
immigration and foreign policy but
unlike others on the talk radio right he
kept his sense of humor and rarely let
anger drown his fundamental optimism
about the united states his great
strength was never to take himself
too seriously limbaugh knew he was an
entertainer not an intellectual or
politician he said so many times he was
popular because he was superb but his
craft and represented traditional
american values that the dominant
culture too often
demeans and that of course is exactly
right
now naturally the left reacted to his
death
by doing exactly what they do with
people they don't like when those people
are alive they took everything that he
ever said out of context
they found his worst comments and they
strung them together to form
the corpus of his life is what cnn did
so cnn
instead of paying tribute to one of the
pioneers of an entire medium
and maybe the pioneer when it came to
the establishment of an alternative
media
of course cnn wouldn't like this because
it breaks cnn's monopoly instead
they ran an entire montage of just
limbaugh's worst low lights right
because to the left that's what
everybody is
you are just a company imagine if your
life at your at your funeral
your life for just all of your worst
moments strung together here's the thing
about rush limbaugh rush limbaugh is on
air live
three hours a day for 30 years for 30
years
it is impossible to speak for three
hours a day for 30 years
and never say anything that you don't
regret
right that is just a fundamental reality
of life but for the left
it's the things that that he said that
offended people or the things that he
said
that he then apologized for that is the
compendium of what rush limbaugh stood
for for his listeners in the same way
that all of the all the worst things
about donald trump that's the stuff you
embrace because the idea here is that
rush was popular because he was bad
right that's the idea is that if you
agreed with rush on fundamental
principles
this also meant that you were in kahoot
with the things that he regretted having
said and so cnn
upon his death they don't run a sort of
tribute to rush
as a human being instead they decide
that it's important that they run a
montage of
a media matters essentially edited
compendium of all of his all of his
heresies
fans known as ditto heads cheered his
brazen style
while critics blasted him for racist
sexist and other offensive speech
he accused actor michael j fox of
exaggerating his parkinson's symptoms
he is moving all around and shaking and
it's purely an act
and he insulted a college student who
advocated for access to birth control
a conservative media icon whose legacy
will always symbolize
division i mean that from cnn from brian
stelter
russia's legacy will always symbolize
division cnn
preceded rush cnn is maybe the most
divisive force in the american media
right now
because they pretend to be objective and
they clearly are not but this is what
they boil down all conservatives do see
it's not about what he said about sandra
fluck
and it's not about what he said about
michael j fox i'm sure he regretted both
of those i think he apologized for both
of those things actually
what it is for the left is that if you
are a conservative you
are all of the worst aspects of you if
you are conservative
then all they want you to remember is
all of that stuff right you don't have
the literally thousands of hours of rush
limbaugh talking
about deep and profound issues you don't
have any clips on cnn rush limbaugh at
the end of his life talking
about how to die with dignity which he
did talk about on his show
instead what you get is that crap hey
this is because this is what the left
thinks of you what the left thinks of
you is that you are that
and they think rush was that rush was
not that rush was by all accounts one of
the kindest people that people had met
tammy bruce
who is a uh who was a former left-wing
radio host
and ended up becoming right-wing has a
beautiful tribute to him today eric
erickson who is always right-wing has a
beautiful tribute to him today
i only had the pleasure of meeting
russian person once and over the phone
i i spoke with him over the phone
actually twice i spoke with him over the
phone because i was in his limbo letter
a couple of times just an absolute
gentleman very kind extraordinarily
generous
when i met him in person rush was
shockingly
retiring he was not the sort of
bombastic figure that you hear on the
air
russia was somebody who has been
described by eric erickson i think
correctly is having a quiet soul
that's who rush was people talk about
the fact that he would
give these enormous tips these five ten
thousand dollar tips at dinner
there are people on both sides of the
aisle who talk about his inflinching
politeness
when he when when you would talk with
him and yet
all cnn can boil that down to is he was
a bad person right that's what cnn is
boiling it down to
and you get the same thing from the new
york times so the new york times ran
this headline this is the headline that
is currently up at the new york times
website quote
rush limbaugh who built talk radio into
right-wing attack machine
dies mr limbaugh 70 who helped transform
the gop
pushed talk radio to the right with
misogynistic and racist language and
conspiracy theories
that is the most dismissive disgusting
and ridiculous headline
that i have read in quite a while from
the new york times not saying a lot they
do this kind of crap
regularly rush limbaugh's legacy
to millions of americans is that he
taught them about conservatism
his legacy to millions of americans is
that he was entertaining about politics
and introduced them to politics
his legacy to millions of americans is
that he gave them a way to fight back
and the new york times boils that down
to he's a racist misogynist
that's what they boil it down to by the
way i should just note some of the other
new york times
obituaries that they've run for public
figures this was run just a few years
ago
mao zedong died on this year in 1976.
the times said he began as an obscure
peasant
and died one of history's greatest
revolutionary figures or
maybe fidel castro here was their obit
when fidel castro you know
the brutal and oppressive cuban dictator
died here was there
here was their headline fidel castro
cuban revolutionary who defied us
dies at 90. how about ayatollah khomeini
you know
the radical anti-semitic genocidal
anti-jew
dictator of iran ayatollah khomeini 89
the unwavering
iranian spiritual leader or how about
this for hugo chavez the venezuelan
dictator
a polarizing figure who led a movement
how about yasser arafat
you know one of the founders of islamic
terrorism yasser arafat father and
leader of palestinian nationalism dies
at 75. so just to get this straight
of all the people i just mentioned mao
castro
khomeini chavez yasser arafat it's rush
limbaugh who deserves the most rage
from the new york times why because rush
threatened their monopoly
that's really what this is about in the
end and so the blue checks were
celebrating last night because that's
what they do because
it is amazing that the people who
consider themselves the most virtuous
are the ones who are crapping all over a
man on the day he dies
see charlotte climber of course tweeting
out rush limbaugh was a coward and white
supremacist white supremacist
he aggressively and cynically exploited
divisions in our country by weaponizing
hatred and bigotry for his own personal
gain
he was in service to his own greed
prejudice and hypocrisy and that is how
history will remember him
just delightful delightful these folks
siobhan thompson r.i.p rush limbaugh
died 69 years later than he should have
beautiful stuff here from the left don't
worry it's rush who's the polarizing
figure you see
these people are all for unity the
excrement shank iger
says wieger says the idea that you say
artificially nice things about people
after they die is weird i've never
understood the logic of it rush limbaugh
was a terrible person while he was alive
he made a living by attacking the
powerless his death does not in any way
change
or redeem that says chenk uighur
he spends his days abusing travel staff
at the airlines
okay this stuff is just i'm sorry it's
just it's just gross there's no reason
to even dwell on it because all it does
is give attention to people who are
desperately seeking it
but the point is broader and that is the
reason that the left hated
rush is because rush was representative
of the fact that there is dissent
because russia did not back down because
russia spoke clearly let's be perfectly
obvious about this
the reason they hate rush is the same
reason they hate everybody who does not
agree with them
because i promise you the reaction to
rush limbaugh's death it will be the
exact same reaction if god forbid
something would happen
to sean hannity or something would
happen to tucker carlson or something
would happen to megan kelly or something
would happen to glenn beck
or something would happen to dennis
prager or something would happen to mark
levin or something would happen to me
the reaction would be exactly the same
exactly the same
it would just be a compendium of the
quote-unquote worst things that we'd
ever said
and then it would be what a terrible
person we're glad they're dead
and the reason they feel that way is
because rush challenged the monopoly
rush changed the paradigm
the left doesn't like that the paradigm
changed the left doesn't decry
polarization because they hate
polarization in and of itself
if they did maybe they'd want to have
discussions with people on the right
occasionally as opposed to trying to
silence them
no the rush believes that russia was
polarizing the left believes that russia
was polarizing
because the left does not like the idea
that there even
is dissent the left does not want there
to be another side of the aisle
everybody knows that they would treat
any person on the right who is not
serving as their
as their unique tool at a particular
time this way if john mccain
had passed away in 2008 while running
against barack obama you heard the exact
same crap about john mccain
if mitt romney had passed away in 2012
while running against barack obama he
would have heard exactly
the same thing because john mccain died
after
having sided with democrats on health
care and after having gone up against
trump
then he was a hero same thing with mitt
romney right now all that matters for
the left
is whether you're a tool for them if you
are not you are an enemy rush was an
enemy and therefore he was to be
destroyed but he refused to be destroyed
and in that lies a bit of inspiration
for all of us i would hope
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content